joel and i have had we had a lot of
prayerful and like really meaningful
conversations over the holidays
and we decided
that we're better
as friends and parents
than we are as an engaged couple
hoda and her fiance joel schiffman have
called it quits after eight years
together
joel is not only a great life partner
he's an unbelievable father the today
show anchor announced the news on the
show monday revealing that while she and
joel have broken up they will remain
co-parents to their two daughters
we decided that we were going to start
this new year
and begin it kind of on our new path
as loving parents to our adorable
delightful children and as
as friends
the pair shares daughters haley who
turns five next month and two-year-old
hope whom they adopted two years after
adopting haley
it is something that um is important to
me and to to joel to us really because
we want her to have a sibling because
she has such interesting circumstances
to grow up in any way so it would be
nice to be able to share it with
somebody and the 57 year old journalist
says she chose to address the status of
her relationship after people had
noticed she wasn't wearing her
engagement ring it's not like something
happened and
you know they say sometimes
relationships are meant to be there for
a reason for a season or for a lifetime
and i feel like ours was meant to be
there for a season the two got engaged
back in november 2019. there are certain
things in your life that just happen
the stars align it's the right moment
and you feel it from deep inside he said
oh and by the way i've loved you since
forever i want to cry thinking about it
but they put off their i do's due to the
pandemic i met the right man at the
right time in my life and joel is the
perfect fit for me
and the fact that i found
the man i've dreamt of and the life i've
dreamt of at this stage in my life
should
should let other women know that
sometimes if you wait it comes later
it's not like you missed it hoda admits
that she struggled with how to share the
news of their split considering she's
been so open about the good times in her
relationship the difficult part
sometimes
you just want to forget about you want
to erase them you don't want to share
them because that's not a part of a
pretty picture
but
i think a lot of women know what this
feels like in this moment to be
um
changing course in life
and i feel really brave in this moment i
really do which is sort of a strange
feeling to feel
but sometimes in your life
you just have to say the truth but now
the emmy winner says she feels a sense
of relief having shared the news
sometimes it just doesn't work and it's
okay
and
to be able to acknowledge it and say to
yourself okay
this is the this is the path that we're
going to be taking from here on so
i feel better that i said i feel better
i feel better there's nothing that
relieves your soul more i think than
when you tell the truth
you